[Música]
[Aplausos]
de manuel macro a un entusiasta del euro
optó por tocar el himno europeo mientras
se dirigía al campo de marte en el
período previo a la votación había
pintado la elección entre elin depender
en doom sobre europa no es de extrañar
pues que la victoria de manuel macro no
haya sido acogida con satisfacción por
los aliados de la unión europea el
canciller alemán olaf scholz con quien
macro mantuvo su primera llamada
telefónica tras la reelección lo
felicito en twitter sus electores
también han enviado hoy un fuerte
compromiso con europa me alegro de que
continuemos nuestra positiva cooperación
usó la fonda legend presidenta de la
comisión europea dijo estoy deseando
continuar nuestra excelente cooperación
juntos haremos avanzar a francia y
europa por su parte el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez dijo que
era una victoria para la democracia y
para europa francia ocupa actualmente la
presidencia rotatoria del consejo de la
unión europea una época desafiante en
medio de la guerra en ucrania la crom ha
encabezado los esfuerzos para suavizar
la crisis
efe
tenemos mucho que hacer y la guerra en
ucrania no se recuerda que atravesamos
momentos trágicos en los que francia
debe hacer oír su voz
de salud
otros asuntos que macro tratará de
abordar en su próximo mandato incluyen
la reducción de la dependencia del
bloque de la energía importada así como
la creación de un proyecto de defensa de
la unión europea